[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginate Se in una notte venissero
portati via tutti gli alberi della
vostra città dalle strade che ogni
giorno percorrete dai parchi dei vostri
quartieri dai cortili delle vostre case
il giorno dopo che cosa vi rendereste
conto di aver perso Ecco sicuramente il
proprietario dell'auto che so stava
sotto uno di questi alberi di qualcosa
si deve essere reso conto gli alberi
raffresca le nostre piazze nelle
giornate assolate intercettano le acque
piovane quando arrivano temporali
depurano l'aria che respiriamo sono
luoghi di
vita oggi sono molti gli studi che ci
aiutano a comprendere i benefici degli
alberi nelle città e l'impatto che
questi hanno su di noi e sulla nostra
salute riconoscere accrescere il ruolo
della natura nel contesto Urbano è stato
un elemento chiave del mio lavoro negli
ultimi 7 anni sono Livia shamir sono un'
architetta e pianificatrice urbana e
lavoro sulla progettazione strat delle
città resilienti del futuro che si
basano sulle infrastrutture Verdi sulle
soluzioni basate sulla natura ma
soprattutto sulle foreste
urbane i progetti che il mio team ha
seguito negli anni spaziano
geograficamente dagli Stati Uniti Al
Medio Oriente fino alle principali
capitali europee questa diversificata
esperienza riflette la mia profonda
convinzione del dover costruire un'unica
visione per le città del
futuro ma perché oggi vi parlerò di
città stiamo attualmente assistendo a
una trasformazione epocale che plasmerà
il nostro mondo nei prossimi tre decenni
e oltre secondo una stima delle Nazioni
Unite ogni settimana 3 milioni di
persone si spostano verso le città è
come se 300 piccoli comuni come Lerici
ogni settimana si spostassero verso le
aree urbane si prevede infatti che entro
il 2050 2.2 miliardi di persone in più
abiteranno le città
le città sono quindi destinate a durare
nel tempo e il futuro dell'umanità è
senza dubbio Urbano il grande tema che
oggi ci troviamo ad affrontare come
architetti come pianificatori ma anche
soprattutto come cittadini riguarda la
trasformazione delle
città le persone che oggi si spostano
verso le città ci abiteranno
probabilmente per tutta la vita che
città ci vogliamo immaginare E
reinventare per loro per i loro figli e
per i loro nipoti che qualità della vita
ci immaginiamo in queste
città le città sono tra le prime cause
del cambiamento climatico sono infatti
responsabili per il 75% delle emissioni
globali ma al tempo stesso ne sono anche
le prime vittime le prime a subirne gli
impatti
negativi per questo La grande sfida oggi
è trasformare le città da essere parte
del problema a divenire le pioniere le
prime protagoniste di un grande
transizione
ecologica oggi invito tutti voi ad
intraprendere con me un viaggio di
scoperta un viaggio che vi svelerà
l'incredibile importanza delle foreste
nelle città e l'impatto che la natura
può avere su di noi e sulla nostra
salute partiamo dal concetto di foresta
urbana potreste chiedervi che cosa
c'entrano però le foreste con la città
bene Molto più di quanto possiate
immaginare Esse sono il punto di
incontro tra gli alberi e le persone e
rappresentano uno snodo cruciale per il
nostro
futuro la Fao l'Agenzia delle Nazioni
Unite per l'agricoltura e
l'alimentazione definisce le foreste
urbane come un sistema complesso di
ambienti urbani o periurbani più o meno
interconnessi che include foreste gruppi
di alberi o singoli
alberi le foreste urbane rappresentano
quindi una sorta di colonna vertebrale
delle Infrastrutture verdi che collegano
le aree rurali delle città al centro
l'incremento globale delle temperature i
modelli di precipitazioni alterate e gli
eventi estremi climatici mettono a dura
prova le risorse delle città e la nostra
vita in
esse Ora vorrei parlarvi di due fenomeni
urbani che ci coinvolgono tutti ma che
ci aiutano a comprendere i problemi che
le città si troveranno ad affrontare in
maniera sempre più intensa negli anni a
venire le isole di calore e il
ruscellamento
l'isola di calore è un fenomeno in cui
le aree urbane Sono caratterizzate da
una temperatura che va da 34° fino a un
massimo di 12° in più rispetto alla
media Ma perché accade tutto questo è
dovuto in gran parte al denso sviluppo
edilizio al consumo di suolo e al nostro
stile di vita
Urbano gli edifici che costruiamo
l'asfalto delle strade che percorriamo e
la nostra attività frenetica
contribuiscono a questo fenomeno tutte
le superfici artificiali assorbono il
calore durante il giorno e lo rilasciano
gradualmente durante la notte questo fa
sì che le città diventino dei veri e
propri forni raggiungendo delle
temperature che non riusciamo più a
tollerare non possiamo ignorare la
realtà dei cambiamenti climatici negli
ultimi anni tutti noi abbiamo toccato
con mano queste temperature estreme
luglio-agosto 2023 Secondo i dati del
sistema di monitoraggio europeo
copernicus sono stati i due mesi più
caldi mai registrati con un'anomalia di
temperatura di 0,72 gr in più rispetto
alla
media qui potete vedere l'immagine
termica satellitare di Milano la città
in cui abito registrata il 18 giugno
2022 le zone rosso intenso che vedete
sono le zone più calde della città
Quindi potete immediatamente riconoscere
la piazza del Duomo la zona della
Stazione Centrale le ferrovie
l'ortomercato le zone più densamente
popolate ma soprattutto da questa mappa
si possono vedere chiaramente le zone
più fresche della città quelle
permeabili e umide con vegetazione e
quindi riconoscete i parchi il Parco
Sempione il parco indromontanelli i
viali Alberati anche il bosco verticale
bene queste sono la nostra speranza in
una giornata di caldo estremo dove
decider reste di andare a
passeggiare in Italia calcestruzzo
asfalto aumentano di 16 Ari al giorno
l'equivalente di quasi 23 campi da
calcio la perdita di suolo naturale e
permeabile causata dall'
impermeabilizzazione delle superfici è
una delle cause delle isole di calore
nelle nostre
città gli alberi riducono e mitigano gli
effetti delle isole di calore in diversi
modi le loro foglie assorbono l'anidride
carbonica e rilasciano ossigeno
migliorando la qualità dell'aria le loro
radici trattengono l'acqua del nel
terreno
raffresca ma soprattutto gli alberi ci
forniscono l'ombra che riduce la
temperatura dell'aria e delle superfici
circostanti ora vi vorrei parlare del
secondo fenomeno Urbano quello del
ruscellamento i modelli di
precipitazione si stanno rapidamente
modificando e questo aumenta
significativamente il rischio di
alluvioni nelle nostre
città le strade diventano rapidamente
fiumi in caso di precipitazioni intense
causando danni a infrastrutture e
abitazioni causando anche l'erosione dei
suoli E persino perdite di vita umane
Qui torna il problema di cui parlavamo
prima la perdita di suolo naturale
permeabile rende le città più
vulnerabili alle alluvioni Perché tutte
le superfici impermeabilizzate come
quelle delle piazze delle strade dei
marciapiedi o dei tetti non riesce ad
assorbire l'acqua in eccesso il fenomeno
quindi che si verifica quando una grande
quantità d'acqua scorre sulla superficie
e non riesce a essere assorbita dal
terreno è chiamato ruscellamento
sempre gli alberi ci possono aiutare a
mitigare questo effetto le loro radici
aiutano a trattenere l'acqua impedendo
che questa scorra sulle superfici le
loro foglie assorbono e intercettano
l'acqua e la rilasciano gradualmente
attraverso l'evapotraspirazione
spero Ormai di essere riuscita a
convincervi di quanti benefici ci
portino le foreste nelle città la
creazione e il mantenimento delle
foreste urbane non sono però prive di di
Sfide gli alberi e le piante richiedono
cura e le politiche di pianificazione
devono poter preservare e ampliare il
verde urbano per fare questo ci vuole
coordinazione tra i diversi soggetti
nonostante le limitate risorse e Il
rapido sviluppo Urbano gli alberi si
fondono discretamente nello sfondo della
nostra quotidianità sono osservatori
silenziosi quando ci riposiamo sotto la
chioma di un albero di un parco quando
passeggiamo per un viale alberato ma
troppo spesso li diamo per scontati
vivere in città ci ha disabituati a
capire gli ecosistemi e a percepire i
benefici che questi ci portano viviamo
infatti in un secolo dove la cultura ci
ha portato a a una sempre più crescente
separazione tra ciò che è artificiale e
ciò che è
naturale ecco per me all'altrove è lo
sconosciuto a volte ciò che abbiamo
sotto gli occhi tutti i giorni ma che
non percepiamo o non riusciamo a
percepire
il termine Plant blindness o cecità
vegetale è stato coniato nel 1998 da due
botanici vanders e schussler ed è la
generale incapacità di umana di vedere o
Notare le piante nel nostro ambiente non
siamo in grado di riconoscere le loro
caratteristiche estetiche o biologiche
si pensa infatti che sia proprio la
nostra intrinseca natura di umani a
farci trascurare l'importanza delle
piante per esempio in questa immagine
cosa notate
immediatamente L'intreccio dei rami
degli alberi o il leopardo appoggiato su
uno di questi rami in uno studio sulla
tensione umana New e tal hanno osservato
che siamo evolutivamente programmati per
concentrarci e reagire più agli animali
che alle piante questo perché in quanto
predatori o prede gli animali sono
essenziali per la nostra sopravvivenza e
la loro fuga o cattura richiede una
reazione immediata uccidi o vieni ucciso
potremmo quindi essere stati programmati
per rilevare e reagire rapidamente agli
animali e di conseguenza filtrare lo
sfondo verde del nostro ambiente sebbene
quindi ci siano fattori biologici
evolutivi e culturali che hanno
influenzato questa nostra cecità La
Rapida urbanizzazione e il nostro stile
di vita hanno peggiorato questa nostra
condizione questo non influisce solo
sulla salute del nostro pianeta ma anche
su quella del nostro ambiente sulla
nostra salute fisica e
mentale qualcosa però sta cambiando le
attuali sfide globali come il
cambiamento climatico il degrado
ambientale il covid-19 hanno aumentato
la nostra consapevolezza dell'importanza
degli spazi verdi nelle città tutti noi
abbiamo sperimentato l'importanza degli
spazi verdi in città per esempio durante
le restrizioni E durante il lockdown
Immagino che tutti noi abbiamo corso
verso un
parco
Nel febbraio 2021 sesil conin andik
esperto mondiale di forestazione di
forestazione urbana e di nature Based
Solutions ha teorizzato il nostro
fabbisogno di spazi verdi nelle città
nasce così la regola del
33300 è una regola abbastanza semplice e
realizzabile questa prevede che tutti
noi possiamo vedere dalla nostra
abitazione almeno tre alberi che nei
nostri quartieri ci sia una copertura
Arborea di almeno del 30% e che lo
spazio verde o parco più vicino disti un
massimo di 300 m dalla nostra
abitazione abbiamo Quindi visto come la
presenza di foreste urbane e alberi sia
essenziale per il benessere e per la
sostenibilità delle comunità Dobbiamo
quindi agire ora per protegere gli
alberi esistenti e per aumentare il
numero delle foreste urbane nelle nostre
città vi devo però confidare che questo
mio discorso di oggi ha dovuto
affrontare un conflitto interiore un
conflitto che mi colpisce sul lavoro
tutti i giorni ed è una lotta tra un
pessimismo
cosmico un senso di impotenza di fronte
alle sfide che il nostro mondo sta
affrontando e la speranza che nonostante
tutto ci sia ancora gli strumenti per
cambiare qualcosa è negabile il nostro
mondo sta affrontando delle sfide senza
precedenti E in queste in Queste sfide
noi ci Riflettiamo e capiamo come le
nostre azioni stiano influenzando le
generazioni future ma in questo
abbraccio al pessimismo dobbiamo
riconoscere una verità fondamentale
l'azione è la nostra risposta Infatti
solo le nostre azioni possono
influenzare il corso degli eventi non
voglio tessere qui illusioni
ottimistiche Siamo di fronte a una
strada impervia e
incerta Ma io vi sfido oggi a guardare
il pessimismo negli occhi e a
trasformarlo in una spinta verso il
[Musica]
cambiamento se il viaggio in cui vi ho
portato oggi Vi è piaciuto e vi ha
convinto allora Potete iniziare anche
voi a fare la vostra parte sarete dalla
parte del cambiamento quando uscite di
casa la mattina Provate a osservare il
mondo vegetale che vi circonda cercate
di capirne lo stato di salute studiate
nei dettagli
piantate nuovi alberi negli spazi
pubblici e privati delle vostre città
nei vostri condomini nei cortili delle
scuole degli ospedali sui vostri balconi
sui tetti Prendetevi anche cura degli
alberi esistenti e proteggeteli unitevi
a gruppi di volontari del verde e
promuovete la forestazione urbana e
divulgate le loro storie e i loro
benefici magari tra 50 o 100 anni
qualcuno potrà ripararsi dal calore
estremo da una violenta pioggia Grazie
all'albero che avete piantato o protetto
voi oggi la natura è l'altrove che
spesso dimentichiamo Ma che dobbiamo
abbracciare per il nostro bene e per
quello delle generazioni future
[Applauso]
Grazie